of the sequence of operations.
Just like we had for stochastic matrices, the unitary matrices are
closed under multiplication, so you'll always get a unitary matrix
when you compose unitary operations.
You have to make sure
you multiply the matrices in the correct order.
But the way it works is just like it was for
stochastic operations where the matrix for the
first operation you perform
will always appear on the right-hand side
of the matrix product, and the last one will appear
on the left-hand side.
So just like before, the order is reversed in the sense that you compose from right to left rather than left to right.
Here's an interesting example that gives rise to an operation known as the square root of not operation.
Suppose that we first
apply a Hadamard operation followed by an S operation, followed by another Hadamard operation.
The combined action of
these three operations is described by this product.
Here's the first Hadamard operation, here's the S operation, and here's the second Hadamard operation.
If we perform the matrix multiplication, which isn't shown here explicitly, but you can do this for
yourself if you wish,
the result is this matrix right here. It's a unitary matrix, and we can either check that directly
or we can trust in the fact that the unitary matrices are
closed under multiplication.
It has to be unitary because these three matrices are unitary as we've already seen.
We don't have any particular
quantum state vector in mind here.
We can imagine performing
this sequence of operations on any quantum state vector, and this matrix describes the action.
The reason why this combined operation, meaning the one described
by this matrix right here is called a spirit of not operation,
is that by performing it
twice, we get a not operation, or in other words, a
sigma x or an X operation.
Performing the operation
twice is represented by squaring the matrix or
multiplying it to itself.
And if you do this, you'll see that the result
is the Pauli x matrix.
And that's kind of peculiar, and it gives you just a hint that you can do some interesting things with quantum information that you can't do with
classical information.
There's no classical operation, meaning one represented
by a stochastic matrix that gives us a not operation
if we perform it twice.
So it's a nice example that reveals that quantum operations
behave very differently from classical operations.
And that's it for lesson one. In this lesson, we discussed how quantum information works for single systems in isolation,
and in the next lesson, we'll talk about how
quantum information works for multiple systems.
Thanks for watching. If you have any questions, feel free to leave them in
the comments section below.